okay you can see we're giving this
octagon right here with an apothem of
six units and we want to find the area
so how do we do that well first thing
you want to do is you want to divide up
this polygon into triangles so you want
to divide it up these all these
triangles are going to be the same
they're congruent triangles and what we
can do is if we find the area of one of
these triangles we can multiply by how
many triangles we have to find the total
area so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna look at this triangle right here
and the first thing we're gonna do is
see how we divided it up into each
triangles because there's an octagon so
if we take 360 degrees divided by e each
one of these central angles here is
going to be 45 degrees but the apothem
what it does is it splits this triangle
into two triangles okay because see how
that's six so that means that each of
these angles here is going to be half of
45 degrees it's going to be twenty two
point five degrees so we want to do now
is we want to find the length of the
side but once we find it we're gonna
have to double it since this apothem is
splitting it into two pieces and a half
so what we're going to do is we're going
to recognize that this is a right angle
and we're going to use our tangent
because we have opposite and adjacent so
we're going to say the tangent of twenty
two point five degrees equals the
opposite side over the adjacent side so
X over six if we multiply both sides by
six we get x equals six times the
tangent of twenty two point five let's
go to the calculator real quick and do
that six tan of twenty two point five it
comes out to about two point five but
we're gonna have to double it since each
of these is two point five so that means
the length of this side here is going to
be five so if we find the area of a
triangle remember the area of a triangle
is one half base times height so it's
going to be one half the base is five
the height is six that gives us 30 times
1/2 which is 15 but we have eight of
these triangles so if we multiply by
eight we get a hundred and twenty square
units now if you want a formula a lot of
students like to use a formula area
equals one-half apothem times perimeter
and the perimeter is a distance of
course all the way around or you can use
1/2 base times height that's the area of
a triangle times n the number of
triangles notice that n times B okay the
base times however many of those bases
you have is equal to the perimeter and
the height of the triangle is the
apothem so the two equations are
equivalent if you want to see another
example finding the area of a regular
polygon check out the other video I did
right there and I'll show you more
examples